[Music]
all right so from the closed guard
variation one is I I use an arm drag of
some kind or a grip of some kind some
kind to get it across whatever maybe
he's grabbing something of mine and I go
ahead and pop
off plus the knee
pull okay get on my side side Circle two
on one into gift
wrap back under knee
push back in and hold both
arms so he's bracing on the knee pull
Bridge up on the hips grab the arm knee
pull you have it again
arm
again third one against the strike
deviate side
again and then from there you have all
your Mountain techniques okay technique
one another opening for the knee pool is
if he's try he's trying in some way to
stand up so he stands up he always goes
one
two okay um so we'll work on the one two
he go you know he's got one foot when
he's about to do the other one that's
when you do the knee pull it's easy
peasy and then you're working the same
technique okay or to do two at the same
time he'll have to get more of an angle
you'll watch this he's more of an angle
to to get up okay so when he goes let me
get the
close so when he goes to get the angle
that's when you do it and it's the same
thing it's easy peasy to get so You'
look for those two things okay those are
when he's given the opening as opposed
to I pulled with a arm drag or arm cross
body to make it happen you can look for
those openings too
okay all right so I'm trying that new p
got it across I'm going here my side
circle is not enough he can get up gets
up okay so when I feel him going up I
change hands and use the space I'm now
in the scissors sweep so I'm still
capping the elbow okay bring him onto
you with your knee scissors sweep you'll
keep the gift wrap then you'll find
the pin at the end one one more
time okay so however you got it boom he
starts to go up change hands
out
on
and so another option uh you got it
doesn't matter okay whatever you got the
knee pull you come up he sits up
he'll take you all the way up we come
over his head
into the hip but swe and then you'll
have to start
your Mount positioning from as if you
started fresh from Mount control
one do it
again look like he's punching boom he
sits up
on around
underhead and
all right let's
try all right so it's it's not as common
as we like to think that someone goes
like flying way over there okay of
course if he does you're you're up
you're just going to take the back
okay but it may
be that he still got a lot of
weight to the side of my Center Line and
you're trying to take him the other way
okay so very important that you add that
and you're cognizant that you're
bringing weight back across your Center
Line instead of trying to throw him from
there okay so as you're coming
around I'm also moving
across so I go from side Circle
and I
move back to the other side now he's not
on the distal side he's on the proximal
side so when I work the
technique he he's more falling
already if you need to you can always
move yourself again more and he'll have
even less Mass so the first point here
is a detail make sure he gets back to
the proximal side and move
yourself as well as move him in the gift
wrap to that proximal side second detail
is you can continually keep moving under
him so for whatever sweep it
is so let's say I got here he starts to
sit up I change SIDS and the same thing
even though I'm bringing them
on maybe my legs aren't strong enough
okay I can again move me to the other
side and it'll be less Mass to
move third
detail
is he's not it's not that he's so heavy
but he's so Bas and out on me okay and
so we already know whether it's the gift
wrap or the scissor that you can come on
the knee push his leg down that makes
his base narrow you can combine this
with you moving out from under him and
he he's already off of you
okay the point is don't push on what's
heavy okay make it lighter all right so
we'll try that let's uh